but we must do this united
not against each other
this is not what she would have wanted
words spoken by helena edwards about the
vigil held for her friend
sarah everard it was a tragedy
a murder a psychopath not a political
movement
her family in anguish grieving a
horrific
loss yet people are holding banners
on clapham common and advocating curfews
for men
my friend's tragic death has been
hijacked it is not a tribute to her
anymore
it's about something else and i don't
like what it has become
she was extremely unlucky that is all
there is to it
those words spoken by helena encapsulate
everything twisted about this campaign
the case is clear this was a homicidal
opportunist who preyed on sarah not a
sexist agenda against women by men
of course when a green party pair
proposed a 6pm curfew
inevitably it sparked outrage from both
men and women
the twitter cesspit was engulfed in fury
but this disgusting publicity stunt or
delusion
whatever it was detracted once again
from the tragedy
we all know men can push the boundaries
and make women uncomfortable
does that mean they're all murder of
course not
and implying otherwise is deeply
concerning
and how toxic can this whole thing
become
some women blaming all men curfews
police brutality
and all the while you have family and
friends
who have lost someone so close yet it's
becoming the second
narrative let's not forget amongst the
chaos
and distraction sarah was found in a
builder's bag on the 10th of march
in a woodland in kent alone
but it was both men and women who tried
their best to find sarah when she was
just missing coming together to help
find this woman who needed
our help stop politicizing sarah's
tragedy
and turning her into a matar when family
and friends haven't asked for it
mourn her death but we must do this
united
and not against each other
you